[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact each September the wood
frogs of Alaska do a very strange thing
they freeze 2/3 of their body water
turns to ice if you pick them up they
would not move if you bent one of their
legs it would break off inside these
frozen frogs other weird physiological
things are going on they stop breathing
their hearts stop beating and their
blood no longer flows to all outward
appearance they're dead the craziest
thing is that they can remain in this
frozen state withstanding temperatures
below zero Fahrenheit for as long as
seven months and then when spring
arrives they thaw out and hop away
they're able to do this because when the
weather turns cold their bodies release
glucose into the bloodstream it acts
like a powerful antifreeze within their
cells when the weather warms up
something within these frogs seems to
spark a resurrection
you know the Bible teaches that if you
have the Spirit of God in you it'll help
you survive the winter of death stay
with us friends we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live you're listening to Bible answers
live honest answers to your Bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 'ah a number
of internet apps we get phone calls from
around the world from people who are
listening as far away as Australia if
you have a Bible question good chance to
get your question on tonight's program
800 four six three seventy to ninety
seven is the number to bring your
questions into our program my name is
Doug Batchelor hi my name is John Ross
good evening pastor Doug and listening
friends let's start the program with
prayer dear father in heaven we thank
you that we have this opportunity once
again to open up your word and then
study these very important truths thank
you for your word it is a lamp unto our
feet a light unto our path and we pray
for your guidance now as we study
together in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor day you started the program
by talking about a remarkable little
frog that for all practical purposes
freezes for multiple months and then
falls out and it's just as if you know
everything's fine and hops along and and
does this thing sometimes when the
weather turns bad and you're gonna have
a frost that people talk about needing
to go outside and cover their plants or
whatever it might be it affects the
fruit and yes here's a frog that freezes
solid and then seems to be just fine
after it those are incredible it is
amazing when you and they've done some
research they actually tagged about 20
of these frogs and wondered how many of
them survive the winter all twenty
survived in the Arctic where it stays
below zero for long periods of time
hey just imagine you could take one of
these frogs stick it in your freezer and
pull it out when you want frog legs no I
don't recommend that friends hit I pull
it out a little later it warms up it's
sort of shivers a little bit it hops
away and not only do frogs do this there
are like certain butterflies you can do
it the imaan arcs freeze sometimes in
the mountains and they thought they fly
away there are some mayflies that do
this snakes and turtles mmm they do it
and it's just a mystery people used to
think they actually froze but they don't
they're the antifreeze in the cell keeps
the frost crystals from piercing the
cells cell wall and making them turn to
mush so they stay alive
folks have wondered scientists have
wondered if dessert some way for people
who are sick to do that to the human
body so they can be frozen and then
resurrected later when there's you know
some cure for their disease they haven't
achieved that yet but Jesus has the
Bible tells us that when people die if
you're a believer they don't really die
they go to sleep until the resurrection
when they wake up and they get a new
glorified body Jesus talks about this in
John 11 verse 25 and 26 he said I am the
resurrection and the life he that
believes in me though he may die he
shall live and whoever lives and
believes in Me will never die and Jesus
own resurrection was evidence for this
and yet some people are so afraid of
death if you have surrendered your life
to Jesus and decided to live for him you
don't have to be afraid of death in many
ways for a believer a death is a sweet
release because your next conscious
thought is the coming of the Lord and
the resurrection and a lot of people
misunderstand these subjects and some
people think you die and go right to
heaven or you go right to hell before
the judgment before the resurrection
there's a little bit of confusion if
you'd like to know about the hope of the
Resurrection and how the Bible says this
is going to happen we have a free study
for you tonight a free offer this
evening is a study guide part of the
amazing facts study guides series
entitled all the dead really dead
dealing with the subject of what
happened
when a person dies if you'd like to
receive this just give us a call on our
resource line that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and as
for the study guide are the dead rarely
did the number again is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and the free offer is are the dead
really dead if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven that's eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven our
first caller this evening is Robin
listening from st. John's Michigan Robin
welcome to the program good evening
pastor Doug Pastor Ross evening my
question is what does the Bible have to
say about gambling and why gambling is
wrong and is there any connection
between ambling and car games like
euchre skip-bo even like poker and
blackjack if they're not played with
money well they're really two questions
here one is gambling the Bible doesn't
speak highly of gambling but you don't
find the word per se you do see where
they gambled for Jesus clothing that the
cross and those of course for the enemy
so that that's probably not a good thing
you do have a scripture that talks about
those that make haste to be rich will
not be innocent and you can read that
and I think proverbs 28 2002 quick I get
rich quickly you know God promises to
bless diligent work it talks about an
inheritance has gotten by diligence and
work will be blessed but one that has
gotten hastily will not be and then the
idea of game of chance where you are
benefiting from everyone else's loss
there's just something first of all
anything that becomes an addiction I
think Christian Christians should right
away know there's a problem I've never
seen anyone addicted to Brussels sprouts
or bananas or anything good it seems
that people get addicted to things that
aren't healthy and we know that some
people get addicted to gambling I've met
people as a pastor counseled with them
seen families destroyed and they lost
everything they lost their inheritance
he lost their house they lost their
marriage because he couldn't stop
gambling you're not going to find
anything about playing poker in the
Bible they didn't do it back then
you ask the second question Robin you
know if you're playing an innocent card
game where you just you know it's a
diversion or maybe you're doing math
along the way like that game Uno or
there's others I don't see anything
morally wrong with that
it's wouldn't you start trying to
basically take the money away from the
other people and you know pile it up for
yourself but without work involved it's
just like these games of chance I just I
I don't think that passes the sniff test
so you would you would say poker or
blackjack if they're just with the chips
like a like a at home play set maybe
that should be steered away from below
the the reason I would have a problem
with that is again that would just be a
game that would just be a game of math
and so forth but once you put it in your
kids hearts or by your example to start
doing these things the Bible says avoid
the appearance of evil and you know
though you may not be doing it for money
just creating the appetite for the game
someone else might say oh I'm gonna
stead of betting plastic chips let's bet
some real money I just would I'd avoid I
don't think I'd see Jesus doing it let
me put it that way all right well I
appreciate your answer alrighty thank
you very much good question my next
caller that we have is Bill listening
from Chicago bill welcome to the program
hi pastor Doug thank you for calling I'm
calling because I was hoping to get some
clarification I read in the Bible where
it says the wait patiently our Lord and
I wondered how long did are you supposed
to wait and risk my ass pieces I have a
wound on the bottom like foot that I've
been fighting for eight or nine months
and dr. Swamy told me today that if I
don't have exchange I could wind up time
mmm so you mean you've been waiting for
the Lord to heal it that doesn't seem
like it's happening and it doesn't and I
know you answers prayer are you
struggling with diabetes yeah and what
happens is they put me on antibiotics
for like 60 weeks and it does finding
starts Ewing in the minute I come home
it goes bad again and they said
because I have an infection in the bone
and it keeps jumping from the bone back
into flesh and if I don't do to imitate
it it could wind up getting into my
bloodstream you feeling
yeah that's pretty frightening yeah that
well first we can't give you any medical
advice here but we would be happy oh no
I'm not looking for that but good you
know I don't know so I just keep praying
and waiting earth does their commentary
you have to say okay guys not going to
answer this prayer and I have to make
the decision myself you know I I would
always tell you you you probably need to
take the sound dependable medical advice
God does use doctors there is a verse in
the Bible you know and I don't doubt the
God can heal but I got to be very
careful not to tell you let's just pray
and then you you know this may not be
God's will and then you have some
terrible medical fallout from that Paul
had a an illness and he prayed about
several times and God said no Paul my
strength is made perfect in weakness you
know some disease is just connected with
the aging process and and so I don't
know what the circumstances are you know
I do know that there's some great
programs online that talk about
reversing diabetes because even if you
do have the surgery that doesn't take
away the diabetes but there's health
practices that the Bible talks about
that can really help you and you know
you could like go to the weimar website
it's just W eim AR Weimar Institute and
there's some others you know medically
sound advice out there and their
Christian based organizations but let me
pray with you would that be okay bill
let's just ask God to give you wisdom
about making a very difficult decision
father in heaven we just want to pause
in our question program here and send
out prayers for bill who's been waiting
for leading and has to make some
important decisions we do pray for you
to heal him and if that's not your will
Lord give him the courage and the wisdom
to make the right choices regarding his
medical conditions and we thank you for
hearing our prayer as we ask in Jesus
name Amen
appreciate your call bill and we'll be
thinking of you
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
one eight hundred seven in DES and she's
listening from Middletown Connecticut
Linda welcome to the program hi pastor
Doug hi how are you Linda I'm very good
thank you and you guys doing great great
my question is should Christians
practice with doing anointing with oil
yes you'll find that mentioned in the
book of James chapter five and it's
pretty clear he says if there's someone
sick they should pray and if you know
necessary if they're stricken you know
they can call the elders of the church
to come and pray over them that's in
James chapter five verse 13 it starts
with and says let them pray over him
anointing him with oil in the name of
the Lord you can also read in mark
chapter six they cast out many demons
and anointed with oil many who were sick
and healed them so the disciples did
this during the life and Ministry of
Jesus and then James the brother of
Christ recommends it high in his book as
well that doesn't mean every time a
person is sick you go grab olive oil but
you know these are people who are in
serious illness and also in addition to
that I I've noticed that many
charismatic churches practice the use of
anointing with oil but it's not like in
connection with healing sick it's more
with the connection of having the holy
spirit right now it is true that in the
Old Testament there when they anointed a
priest or a king and they pray for the
spirit to come on them such as salt or
David and others
who else ji who was anointed with oil by
Elijah the spirit would come on them and
it was a symbol of that you don't really
have people being anointed with oil to
receive the spirit of the New Testament
at Pentecost you know Jesus sent the
Holy Spirit to the whole Upper Room
right and no oil was involved but the
two examples you have in the New
Testament it's connected with people who
are sick that's what I thought and
that's Mark 6 and James that will go to
James chapter 5 I hope that helps a
little bit Olinda and you know if if you
have something that serious issue like
that you could call for your elders and
it's not just charismatic churches I
know a lot of evangelical churches are
Church we practice anointing with oil
for sick sick people appreciate your
question Linda next caller that we have
is Roger listening in Colorado Roger
welcome to the program thank you for
having me I've been doing a little Bible
study and I'm being challenged on two
little small phrases one of them is in
Revelation 1:10 and the other one is
somewhere in the book of Joel the Lord's
Day and the day of the Lord
two different phrases are they the same
thing no well let me read this for our
friends listening in the book of
Revelation John describes he received
the revelation the vision Jesus appeared
to him he says I was in the spirit on
the Lord's Day now many has said well
the Lord's Day well that must have been
Sunday but there's nothing in the text
or in anywhere else in the Bible that
says that it's just sort of a tradition
that's been picked up and repeated if
you want to know what the Lord's Day was
John was he was sent as a captive on the
Isle of Patmos and a slave really to
work in the mines that the Romans had
there but he refused to work on the
Sabbath day in the Bible the Jews often
called the sabbath the lord's day and
you can read in or does it isaiah 58 he
calls the sabbath my holy day and in the
ten commandments it's called the sabbath
of the lord your god
the day of the lord on the other hand is
speaking of that great Judgment Day when
the Lord comes and the great judgment
falls in the world so these are these
are two different things
Joel chapter 2 I think is talking about
the great judge
one day yes well that's what I've been
trying to tell these people that are
trying to teach me a little more nice
wait a second
the Lord's Day is the Sabbath oh it
isn't it's a particular day the week I
said okay the Sabbath is the seventh day
of the week
so there's your particular day well no
it can't be that yeah well you just to
do inductive Bible study you just go
from verse to verse and I can think of
about a half a dozen here's one more
verse is it mark chapter 2 where Jesus
said son of man is also Lord of the
Sabbath mm-hmm and so there's one more
in the New Testament where Jesus says
the Sabbath is the Lord's Day the day of
the Lord is that's always speaking of a
time of judgment it was the destruction
of Jerusalem and some of the prophecies
of like Isaiah and Jeremiah and it's the
second coming and a number of other Old
Testament prophets the first you figured
off there is Mark chapter 2 verse 28
since therefore the Son of Man is Lord
also of the Sabbath we do have a study
guide that talks about the Sabbath and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks it's called last day in
history it's part of our amazing fact
study guide series the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again half of the study
guide called lust day in history one
journal God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 seven two seven
five we've got Jerry listening from
Oregon Jerry welcome to the program
thank you pastors John my question
pertains to polygamy I've heard both of
you
well these pastor Doug rather mentioned
that this is contrary to God's will and
occurred many pastors mentioned the same
thing but now in second Samuel chapter
12 verses seven eight nathan is rebuking
David for his stealing of another man's
wife and can I quickly read it to you
sure I've got it open here but go ahead
this is what the Lord the God of Israel
says I anointed you king over Israel and
they delivered you from the hand of Saul
I gave your master's house to you and
your masters wives unto your arms I gave
you all Israel and Judea and if all this
has not been had been too little I would
have given you even more so he's saying
he's given them very a lot of desirable
things which evidently he's implying
that that David was not appreciative of
but one of these was wives plural his
master's wives and the Lord gave yeah I
think the Lord is simply saying there
you took the wife of your servant of one
of your soldiers Uriah this was another
man's wives nathan is explaining a
parable he's talking about this man that
had flocks and herds lots of sheep and
he took his neighbor's one lamb and and
killed it and he's saying look Uriah had
one wife you had all these wives from
your conquests and the concubines that
you got when you took the throne of Saul
it's not that God was approving polygamy
he was just showing the ingratitude and
the voracious appetite that David had
developed through his power yeah I don't
believe I don't think that's a good
verse to say God supports people having
multiple wives he's really interpreting
a parable there well he says but he gave
his masters wives which would have been
assault wives - David yeah I think it's
just he's really saying what the Kings
did back then when one King conquered
another king he often took his harem his
harem God is just saying you had all
harem full of wives why did you take
your loyal soldiers wife I don't think
it's same 'god approved of his doing
that jerry do you think polygamy is okay
well you know III we condemned certain
phase for practicing polygamy in years
past I don't know whether that's
biblically grounded I don't think it's
practical and furthermore there wouldn't
be there be too many men without wise if
one man had a thousand so you know my
when you look in the Bible um well first
of all the Bible says no man can serve
two masters so that's a verse right
there God made one wife for Adam the
example in the Bible for someone who's
gonna qualify to be an elder it says
husband of one wife and so clearly by
the time of Christ you know Jesus said
God allowed many things because of the
hardness of the heart and I forget that
verse pastor Ross for Christ said they
said why did is it Matthew nineteen
where the disciples are saying why did
in most say give a bill of divorce and
Jesus said because of the hardness of
your hearts well God allowed people in
the Old Testament they had slaves and
they had multiple wives not that he
proved these things but the hardness of
their hearts it's Matthew 19 verse 8
yeah I I don't think that and everyone
who had multiple wives looked at the
fighting that went on in Abraham's house
and look at the fighting and the
squabbling that went on in Jacobs house
and look at the fighting between hannah
and peninnah
the wives of Elkanah there was never
peace in the home when you had women
rivaling for their husband's affection I
mean well husband misery anyway but I
hope that helps a little bit Jerry and
but yeah we can't really give you a
study guide on that cuz I think that's
sort of a self-evident truth but we
appreciate your question next caller
that we have is Damien listening in
California
Damien welcome to the program hi good
afternoon I thank you for calling thank
you pastor awesome pastor dad I have a
question to ask you
listen I have been reading a lot of
amazing sex publications and booklets
and stuff like that more so than I even
read the Bible and lately I would have
been said lately like many months ago I
started I am NOT able to focus in Troy
what I'm trying to say is that every
time when I kneel down in prayer nothing
comes out of my mouth I seem to come to
to draw a blank facing a blank wall
nothing comes out my mouth like I'm just
frozen don't know what to say so as a
result just sit on the floor on my knees
just draw a blank just complete blank I
don't know how to play I just realized
that I don't know what to do
does that mean that does that mean that
God's good has been withdrawn from Sony
for some reason no I don't think so
first of all you probably want to be
calling and asking for help if God's
Spirit had been withdrawn you would be
ambivalent about it I believe that the
devil can sometimes create a buffer that
we need to you know get a breakthrough
on when you pray you know you're allowed
to open your eyes why don't you write
down some things that you know you need
to pray about pray first of all for your
spiritual state you can just say to the
Lord what you just said to me Lord how
come I am having trouble getting through
I'll write it down and read it to the
Lord you can talk about ask him for
health and strength ask him for an
opportunity to share your faith pray for
your loved ones make a list of their
names so write out a list of what you
want to say to the Lord and you're gonna
find that as you start doing that you'll
start filling in between the blinks
things you haven't written down you know
we have a book called let me share this
book with you before we run out of time
for our break that's called teach us to
pray and it goes through some principles
talking about how can we make pray more
meaningful okay okay and how would I
know if God's Spirit didn't leave me yet
how would I know that are you convicted
of your sins if you're doing something
wrong do you feel impressed that you
shouldn't do it the Holy Spirit is the
one who convicts us of our sin according
to Christ and I think that's John 14 you
know if if do you have any desire to see
the law saved it's the spirit that gives
you that desire when God withdraws his
spirit from you usually you're overcome
with selfishness and pride and you just
have lost your your interest in
listening to his voice now I'm not the
Holy Spirit I'm not God I can't read
heart
but Jesus said you'll know them by their
fruits and it seems to me that you're
you still got the fruit where you're
looking and listening we'd encourage you
to get that book I think you'll find it
very helpful it's simply called teach us
to pray and the number for that is 883
five six seven four seven and we'll be
happy to send that anyone who calls and
asks again the name of the book is
called teach us to pray our next caller
that we have well pastor like do we have
time to take another call yeah maybe we
better wait we don't want to just give a
person 50 seconds for their question
we're not going away friends we've got
more Bible questions coming in fact you
can even pick up your phone and call now
if you don't get picked up right away
those operators just let it ring a
minute and they'll get to your question
we'll answer them typically we do it in
the order they're received every now and
then if there's a double on a question
we'll we'll jump past one but on the
number eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven also want to
mention that the amazing facts website
is really the mothership of all we do if
you want to find out more about the
resources archives of these programs the
books that we've written that we offer
Bible studies lessons free downloads
videos we have millions of YouTube hits
and just go to amazing facts dot o-r-g
we're coming back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Corrine was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Corrine to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Corrine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend have an
opportunity to help someone today and to
make an eternal difference from where
people like Corrine you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o-r-g or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight thank you for studying the
Word of God with me today and I hope
that you'll plan now to join me again
next week as we discover more amazing
facts from the
of God every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 7 to 97 my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross and we have some callers that are
standing by we have Michael listening in
Danville Virginia Michael welcome to the
program hey how are you guys doing
tonight
great thank you appreciate your calling
in um actually I had a question I was
baptized years ago and I had some hard
times in life of course and I've kind of
gotten away but I've come back and
actually I just want to take a moment to
appreciate the millennium or prophecy
was the reason it actually brought me
closer to the Bible and closer to Jesus
so I just want to say thank you for that
amen and um I've been baptized and you
know of course the world tends to drag
you here and there is it okay or is it
biblical to be when you're rededicated
to be rebaptised or how do you feel on
that subject well there are examples in
the Bible of course you know the most
important thing is what does the
scripture say there are a couple of
examples in the Bible of people who were
rebaptised
you have in acts 19 here's one
and starting with the first verse says
it happened while Apollo's was at
Corinth at Paul having passed through
the upper coasts in the region came to
Ephesus finding some disciples he said
to them did you receive the Holy Spirit
when you believe I said we've not so
much as heard whether there is a Holy
Spirit he said into what then will you
baptize so here they were baptized they
said John's baptism John baptized by
immersion the right process Paul said
John indeed baptized with the baptism of
repentance saying to the people they
should believe on Him who would come
after him that is on Jesus we heard this
they were baptized in the name of the
Lord Jesus and then Paul lays hands on
them they received the Holy Spirit so
they were baptized twice I was baptized
twice his first time I got baptized I
people just some baptist friends as
hurry up and baptized me for I really
was grounded or discipled and I actually
got in trouble for the Sun went down
that day a couple of years later I was
baptized after being discipled and
taught Jesus said go therefore teach
baptizing so baptisms like marriage you
don't want to you know be getting
baptized every few months anymore you
want to get married every few months you
want your baptism to stick but if you
wander from the Lord in a big way just
like if you divorce your spouse
technically you got to get remarried so
if you wander from the Lord or if you've
come into a whole new understanding of
what conversion is you may want to
publicly declare that through rebaptised
talk to your pastor I'm assuming you go
to church talk to your pastor and and
see what their take is on this and I'm
sure that they'll support helping me do
the right thing no right I appreciate
that a whole lot of this it was curious
in my mind cuz you know I've I've always
read the word and we gotten back into it
and I just wanted to see if that was
something that would you know it's a
good thing as far as biblical to do and
you know what when in doubt do the safe
thing and I've not known a person who
was rebaptised that was regretted it if
the spirits are urging you to do it and
you do it you'll probably have peace by
the way in the Millennium of prophecy
series you mentioned some people still
have the old VHS tapes and I don't know
where you'd play them but I
think you can even watch them online now
and I have one on baptism where I talk
about rebaptised mand you can even look
at that we also have a book called
baptism is it really necessary talks
about baptism and re baptism we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number is 883 five six
seven four seven as for the book baptism
is it really necessary
next holy is Tom listening from Lincoln
Nebraska Tom welcome to the program
hello my question is is the perfection
of the character or supposedly the
absolute perfection of the character and
necessary to receive salvation well
let's answer your question with a
question
there was a thief hanging on the cross
next to Jesus when Jesus was crucified
and he said Lord remember me when you
come into your kingdom
and Jesus said to him verily I say to
you today this is Luke chapter 24 or 23
you will be with me in paradise will
that thief be saved well Jesus said okay
how perfect was his character I mean how
much time did he have to sanctify and
perfect his character not very much so
he's going to be saved based on his
perfect character he's going to be saved
based on faith and the justification
that Jesus offered him freely from the
cross all of us are saved by faith
nobody's saved by works now if you are
saved by faith your works will be
different and we will always strive to
be following a perfect Savior no
Christian should ever be satisfied with
anything less than the perfection of
Christ but don't beat yourself up if
you're not perfect because that would
really disqualify everyone I know he's
got you know their head screwed on
straight that's a Christian feels like
they have a long way to go you know when
we talked about Christian perfection of
course the Lord wants us to be holy but
if you ask a genuine Christian out there
are you perfect I've not met anyone that
says yes even the Apostle Paul says I do
not count myself to of
handed neither to be perfect but then at
the end of his life Paul said I have
fought the good fight I have kept the
faith I've finished the course and I
know there is laid up for me a crown of
righteousness so he had faith that he
would be saved but I don't know where
along the way Paul considered himself
perfect you know we have a book dealing
with the subject of living the Christian
life it's called life in the spirit and
I think you'd find that helpful Tom or
anyone wanting to learn how do we as
Christians love what is the goal and of
course any type of obedience if it's
worth anything must be motivated by love
if our reason to obey God is to somehow
win salvation then you think the
motivation will be selfish but if we
love God and we want to serve Him and do
those things pleasing to him well that's
a whole different motivation for why we
try to do the things that please him
maybe happy to send this book to anyone
who calls and ask the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and again it's
called life in the spirit we'll be happy
to send it to you Tom or anyone who
gives us a call we have Becky listening
from Michigan Becky welcome to the
program hello how you guys doing good
hi Becky and your question um what is
fasting how I go about fasting so this
year we're going to have meetings in
September every point there is a month I
have to fast and I don't know how well
there's different ways to fast and it
depends on you personally your choice
some fasting a serious fast and I don't
recommend this but like a life-and-death
fast the Apostle Paul and Esther they
did not eat or drink food but you can't
do that for very long or you'll die
some fasting means you simply don't eat
food and it might mean you don't eat
food for a meal you skip a meal and some
fasting and then Daniel I think it's
Daniel chapter 9 where he says I eat no
Pleasant meat no Pleasant food Daniel
went on a fast where he basically just
ate very simple light food ate very
little food to just keep him keep his
strength up but he was fasting and
praying and so that's another way to
fast you're denying yourself usually
food too you know some people say I'm
going on in electronics fast I'm not
gonna do any social media I'm not going
to be you know on TV or
Keter and i'm gonna spend time in prayer
and you know i'm i know people that have
experienced revival because we're doing
that typically in the bible of fast
meant you don't eat that's why when you
eat breakfast breakfast gets its name
from breaking the fast of the night
you've been fasting all night while you
sleep you break your evening fast with
your first meal in the morning fasting
means you don't eat the Jews would
sometimes fast where they would fast all
through the day but then they'd eat
after sundown and many Muslims do that
during Ramadan they fast all day then
they'll have something like to eat well
it gets the Muslims feast so it's more
than life yeah yeah so the juice needs
something light before they went to bed
does that help a little Becky and then
you fast and mix that with prayer and I
think you'll see God will do things it's
a saying that God's more important than
our physical needs when we fast okay
thank you I appreciate your call make
fun of it we have is Edward listening
from Texas Edward welcome to the program
hello is this um in my life
you're alive yeah you might want to turn
your radio down you're gonna hear us
talking double okay hi sorry I was not
prepared um hey pastors hi
so my question my question has to do
with in Matthew chapter 24 when Jesus
said let those that be in Judea flee to
the mountains so my question is one that
when the Sunday law is getting ready to
be or when the mark of the beast is
getting ready to be enforced when what
should as somebody who doesn't live you
know near mountains or what's the what's
the solution and I wish it what should
one do in that circumstance
now when Jesus makes that statement in
Matthew chapter 24 I think it's also in
Luke 21 when you see Jerusalem
surrounded with armies let those that be
in the city or Jerusalem I forget he
said Judea flee into the mountains well
they were surrounded by mountains in
Judea Christ is answering a question
about not only his return and his and
the signs of and he's asking answering a
question about the destruction of
Jerusalem so for one thing Christians
that were in Jerusalem when the Roman
armies came they knew that was a signal
to get out of Dodge and to head out in
the hills and
most of them survive that listen to the
prophecy in the last days God's people
are going to be handed in by the laws of
the Beast and when we see that there are
laws that are restricting our worship
telling us that we can't buy or sell
unless we observe the law of the Beast
we're gonna have to probably leave even
some of the suburban areas and head to
more remote places because otherwise
they'll be severe persecution in the
cities hey we appreciate your your
question on that Edward and I hope that
helps a little bit you know we do have a
study guide called the mark of the beast
that gets into this and gives you the
different prophecies in the Bible that
references this to receive the study
guide call 808 three five six seven four
seven after the study guide talking
about the mark of the beast again that's
808 three five six seven four seven sue
is listening from Missouri sue welcome
to the program good morning pastors I
mean good evening it's morning somewhere
yeah I guess thanks sue and your
question you had just posted on Facebook
little video about is it a sin to eat
pork now I know the concept I know when
God said that something's an abomination
you know you don't eat it but not
everybody knows that concept and so one
of my friends I shared that video and so
one of my friends put on there I wonder
why he left out Romans 14 and I thought
you did an excellent job on the video
myself that somebody's always going to
look for something right you know to ask
about it and so I thought well maybe you
could go over Romans 14 and just explain
a few of the things in there sure happy
to and yeah you know I do a question
typically I do the Bible question of the
week they put them up on my Facebook
page I think it's also in the amazing
facts page on Friday evening and I
didn't run a few weeks ago is it a sin
to eat pork they generated quite a bit
of buzz but I was basically reading what
the scriptures say now in Romans 14 Paul
is he's talking really about a big
debate that was happening pastor also
looked this up where he says he was sold
in the marketplace or the shambles ask
you know
questions for conscience sake and you'll
find that verse for me
it says Romans 14 1 receive one who is
weakened faith but not to disputes over
doubtful things for one believes he may
eat all things but he who is weak eats
only vegetables all right let's stop
right there is it saying that only weak
people are vegetarians actually many of
the Ironman triathlete s' are vegan
vegetarians or vegetarians and Carl
Lewis was a vegetarian who broke all
those records so the Bible is not saying
vegetarians are weak because science
shows the opposite he's talking about
people who are weak in faith they were
afraid if they bought food in the Greek
in the Roman marketplace that had been
sacrificed to an idol they were guilty
of idolatry that would be the equivalent
of somebody today going to a Chinese
restaurant where they got a statue of
Buddha being afraid that you're
worshipping Buddha by eating in that
restaurant
they were very sensitive to these things
had nothing to do with what the food was
no particular food is mentioned anywhere
in this chapter do you have that verse
yeah the first Corinthians chapter 10
verse 25 and starting verse 24 it says
let no one seek his own but each one the
other is well-being in other words we
need to be mindful of those around us
first 25 eat whatever he sold in the
market or the meat market asking no
questions for conscience sake yeah so
you don't when they went to the meat
market don't ask if this goat or sheep
or chicken or whatever it was these are
clean foods what sacrifice did you put
her or Paolo before they hung it up in
the butcher mark he said if you ask that
vineyard you're gonna be guilty of
feeling oh well maybe I'm worshipping
one of these pagan gods that was the big
debate in the Bible they were never
debating you'll never hear anyone the
New Testament say you can eat pork you
just don't find that they believe matter
of fact Peter says in Acts chapter 10 I
have never eaten anything common or
unclean and this is three and a half
years after Jesus price had never told
the disciples that all of a sudden you
know Christians can eat anything
Christians evangelical Christians do not
believe that you can eat anything
without consequences you will not accept
your child telling you that I'm going to
eat candy bars before I go to school
instead of
some nutritious breakfast because I'm
gonna pray over it and God says all
foods are clean we know that's
irresponsible God is not mocked
you're gonna reap what you sow pork is a
filthy meat they are filthy animals they
may be intelligent as a pit but the
Bible says that their flesh is an
abomination
pigs are scavengers their bodies are
full of their meat is full of disease
and sodium and carcinogens and not to
mention that most water houses still
have the blood and acts 15 says you
shouldn't need blood
so ya don't eat pork it's nasty hey hey
wait this little piggy went to the
market this little piggy stayed home
this little piggy ate roast beef even a
pig won't eat pork I think most people
know that all right well thanks you coal
sue my next one of the behalf is calling
from pardon me one more thing hey sue we
have a book you can download it's called
hogs and other hazards if you want you
can download that and there's another
one I think it's called death in the
kitchen and I'm gonna call for that he's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called hogs and other hazards or another
book called death in the kitchen I've
got an intriguing title and well happy
to send it out to anyone who calls and
asks if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
looks quality we have is Bob and he's
calling from college place Washington
Bob welcome to the program
no pastor Ron hi and your question this
evening I missed you last week
oh that's right I was gone well I was
calling about Hebrews 8 verse 13 it I'm
wanting to know is what is becoming
obsolete and growing old the Ten
Commandments so I've heard people say
that before a couple of times
yeah the Ten Commandments are course not
obsolete when he says the first covenant
a covenant is an agreement when two
people get married the man and the woman
they pledged vows they are making a
covenant they're making an agreement if
you enter into a contract with somebody
and you say I will buy your house for
ten thousand dollars and they say okay I
accept your offer you write it down you
have a covenant it's an agreement the
covenant of the Old Testament was when
the people said to God and this is I
think it's in is this an exodus 20 at
the end where and after God gives the
Ten Commandments that people said all
the Lord has said we will do then they
broke all the commandments they
worshipped the golden calf the law the
Ten Commandments was written on Moses
Casso stones out of the his hand the
people broke the covenant God says I'll
make a new covenant I will take my law
and put it in their heart so the Old
Covenant was based on the promise of the
people all the Lord has said we will do
the new covenant God says I will write
my law in their heart it's God doing it
in a new place
same law it is still wrong to lie it is
still wrong to kill it is still wrong to
steal or commit adultery to worship
other gods and so forth so I think every
Christian knows through common sense the
Ten Commandments are part of God's
eternal moral law but the New Covenant
is he writes it in our hearts and he
said he will do it I will cause them so
the Old Covenant based on the promises
of man that has vanished away it's now a
promise based on God based on Christ you
know we do have a study guide Bob you
might find interesting actually a book
that we could sing to you or anyone is
cold why did the Old Covenant fail deals
with is very
object the number to call is 883 five
six seven four seven and after the study
guide we'll actually the book rather why
the Old Covenant fail begin their number
is 883 five six seven four seven annex
cola that we have is sherry listening
from bearing Springs Michigan sherry
welcome to the program hi thank you for
having me pastors my question is about
the role of the Holy Spirit in the
Godhead I've read your book exploring
the Trinity and so my question I guess
is I guess I always thought that God had
was just a little bit different than
actually three separate persons I'm
reading a straight person so when Jesus
was baptized the Holy Spirit came down
in the form of a dove and then in John
20:22 when he gave the Holy Spirit to
the disciples did the Holy Spirit then
just stay on the earth this whole time
so he's still with us but did he come
and go again or is he just always been
here and and that the Holy Spirit is
actually part of God is still here with
us is that am I understand that
correctly well let me back you up a
little further we'll go to Genesis 1
where it says God the Spirit of God
moved on the face of the water so you
got the Holy Spirit in Genesis 1 now you
go to the last chapter in the Bible
which is revelation 22 and it says the
spirit and the bride say come the Spirit
of God if he had ever left the world
every living thing would die God's
Spirit has always been with people but
he comes into people's hearts in
different degrees with a different
emphasis at different times you know
Bible says the Spirit of the Lord came
on Sampson I think even supernatural
strength Jesus breathed on the Apostles
and said receive the Holy Spirit so they
had the Holy Spirit why Christ was alive
Jesus sent them out teaching and
preaching and they received the special
baptism of the Spirit in Acts chapter 2
at Pentecost right but then you go to
acts 4 and they pray and the Spirit
comes again and the place is shaken and
they're empowered they don't speak in
tongues but they speak the Word of God
so the Holy Spirit just comes in waves
he's always been here
and God has never withdrawn his spirit
to send the promise of the Holy Spirit
God the spirit it has always been in the
world it's the agency or the person of
God that speaks to our hearts and works
within us jesus said he leads us he
convicts us of sin he brings comfort he
declares he brings through our
remembrance the things that crisis said
so when Jesus actually left and
descended ascended to heaven he left
basically part of himself behind because
if this the father got the son of the
Holy Spirit like three and one he left
part of himself behind is that correct
no I see that's what I'm well first of
all we're we're on holy ground when
we're talking about this because for a
man to describe God and really
understand all the nuances you'd almost
have to be God what we can just describe
is what we do know they are three
separate persons you know the Bible says
baptize in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit Jesus when he's
on earth and he prays to his father
clearly Christ and the father are
separate beings right mm-hmm
so for Jesus to say it's expedient that
I go that when he the spirit of truth is
come again Christ we're getting clearer
picture they're distinct and as you
mentioned at the baptism you've got the
father in heaven the son in the water
the Spirit coming down like a dove and
Pentecost the Spirit comes down like
fire Jesus told John you know he told
Nicodemus the spirit can be like wind so
the Holy Spirit is the hardest person of
the Godhead for us to visualize because
he's the spirit you know Jesus spiritual
things are spiritually discerned
and Jesus he'd been told the woman at
the well god is a spirit he those who
worship Him must worship Him in spirit
and in truth it's a deep subject I'm
sorry I hope that's making a little bit
of sense sherry and that we appreciate
your call sounds like you got my book
which is my best effort to try and
explain a very deep subject don't be
discouraged friends if you don't
understand everything about the nature
of God as the heavens are high above the
earth soar his ways above our ways let's
see if we can get in one more question
pastor Ross
we have Sharon Griffin
from Bronx New York welcome to the
program hi Doug and John hi I would like
to know I have the number could you send
me a book on how to stop smoking
cigarettes and then I want to ask you a
question about the first book of Samuel
okay and go ahead ask you a question
okay it's all chapter 1 and it says the
son of Eli who the first book of Samuel
yes I don't think that's the same person
you know and yo dirty to Flora no I
don't think it's the same person because
the character in Jobe goes back quite a
ways before Samuel job job and his
ancestors they lived just a little after
the time of Esau quite a bit of time
went by through the Exodus before you
get to Samuel and elkanah
hundreds of years went by so I don't
think it's the same person it's not an
uncommon name and you know in the Bible
some names appear many many times and
that may be a name that's appearing more
than once there's even more people in
the Bible there's about three or four
people named Jesus I can think of maybe
four and there's two people I know of
named Daniel and two or three named
Moses in the Bible hey and by the way
we're gonna for we lose you Sharon you
can quit smoking I used to smoke God
wants to set you free you know see I
don't mean to cut you off I don't mean
to cut you off well I can ask 22nd you
don't do you happen to have a book on
that that I could call we do have we've
got books that we can offer you yes ask
for the book Sharon if you'll call the
number I think you said you had the
number ask for the book the power of a
positive no because that's where I think
where it comes to you know you pray
about it but you want to make a positive
decision to turn away from that which
you know is not the will of God and
we'll be happy to send it to you as for
the book the power of a positive note
yep and just call 808 three five six
seven four seven friends you can tell
from the music we're gonna have to sign
off till next week god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com in six days
God created the heavens and the earth
for thousands of years man has worshiped
God on the seventh day of the week now
each week millions of people worship on
the first day what happened why did God
create a day of rest does it really
matter what day we worship who is behind
this great shift discover the truth
behind God's law and how it was changed
visit Sabbath truth com journey back
through time to the center of the
universe discover how a perfect angel
transformed into Satan the arch villain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word
visit our website at
www.lazyguycooking.com which offers
thousands of inspiring books DVDs and
more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]
you